ja ich begrüße alle zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer auf die lowcost zum kurzen
rückblick
wir wollen den heutigen sitzung wir uns
mit dem thema nicht existenz oder auch
existenz bei alexius meinung einen sehr
unbekannten denker befassen werden aber
bevor wir darauf eingehen noch um
kleinen rückblick machen und zwar zu
ganz verschiedenen themen die aber alle
doch miteinander zusammen hängen nämlich
mit david hume mit diesem netten herren
hiermit dieser schicken perücke diesen
prächtigen gewandt und ich hatte schon
gesagt letzte mal david hume ist ein
aufklärer also 18 jahrhundert und der
ist eigentlich so eine art vorgänger von
kant kannte hatte viele vorgänger
immanuel kant aber kant hat eben ganz
prominent gesagt dass david hume ihn aus
dem dogmatischen schlummer geweckt haben
und das ist ein großes kompliment eines
der größten komplimente was kennt
wahrscheinlich jemals gemacht hat und
dieses kompliment hat eben david hume
bekommen und jetzt kann man sich
überlegen wofür hatte dieses kompliment
bekommen sicherlich für verschiedene
dinge für einen jeden fall ein
kritisches denken kritisches denken
heißt das kant damit meint dass die
teams sich über unsere
erkenntnismöglichkeiten und die grenzen
unserer erkenntnis sehr klare gedanken
gemacht hat und wie er sich über unsere
erkenntnis gedanken gemacht hat der
videos so auch über den begriff die
existenz um den ja dieses seminar sich
trägt und wir hatten so ein paar
leitfragen in der letzten sitzung wie
bestimmten die vorstellung von existenz
vielleicht auch den begriff von existenz
wie verhalten sich essenz und existenz
nach jung zueinander
denken sie an diese zentrale
unterscheidung die im mittelalter bei
absender aber auch bei thomas von aquin
aufgemacht wurde wenig mit kontext
bestimmt
den begriff der existenz ist war eine
weitere frage inwiefern ist nach kant
existenz kein reales prädikat und die
letzte frage wie vernunft an tand jugend
bei seiner bestimmung dass existenz
begriffs an das ist jetzt also so weit
waren dass sie fragen wir haben
vielleicht noch eine hier in die finden
gibt kanten leibnitz bei seiner
bestimmung des existenz begründen
das sehen sie daran dass kant auch redet
von analytischen setzen wer nennt sie so
und das ist nach leibnitz dann ein
essentieller satz ich mach oben rechts
ein youtube-video die verknüpfung zum
zur zusammenfassung bei leibnitz rhein
wo sie das ganze nochmal nachlesen
können so also david hume befasst sich
mit dem griff der existenz im rahmen
seiner im puristischen erkenntnis und
bedeutungs theorie nach dieser
erkenntnistheorie müssen wir alle unsere
vorstellung und begriffe von bestimmten
dingen eben auch von existenz auf
bezahle eindrücke die nennt er
impressions zurückführen damit sie
bedeutung haben
es gibt natürlich gewisse ideen oder
vorstellungen begriffe die nach humes
sinnlos sind wenn sie sich nicht auf
einen eindruck zurückführen lassen
jetzt habe ich ihnen das mal so ein
bisschen mit einem schema hier
demonstriert also wir haben jetzt eine
gewisse vorstellung gewissen begriff da
können sie alles möglich einsetzen
und der muss sich zurückführen lassen
auf einen unmittelbaren sinnes eindruck
und wenn das möglich ist dann hat diese
vorstellung dieser begriff bedeutung
jetzt kann man das anhand des beispiels
die existenz machen das jetzt auch mal
ein begriff der vorstellung das kann man
sich fragen auf was von sinnes eindruck
ist existenz zurück zu führen oder es
existenz zurückzuführen auf den
sinneseindruck plus noch was also plus
die existenz selbst gibt es so einen
sinn ist eindruck von der existenz der
zusätzlich zum zins eindruck wie zum
beispiel rot oder grün oder laut oder
stimmten gemacht werden kann und das
bestreitet jung also jung untersucht wie
es mit der vorstellung der existenz
aussieht steht für ihn fest dass jede
vorstellung jeder sinneseindruck als
existieren vorgestellt oder wahrgenommen
hat also das ganze läuft darauf hinaus
dass jeder sinneseindruck bereits seine
existenz als sinneseindruck verbirgt und
nicht noch eine zusätzliche wahrnehmung
braucht die dann die reine form der
existenz bedeutet jetzt gibt es für
jugend trotzdem zwei möglichkeiten und
ich habe das in meiner zusammenfassung
dann einen destruktiven zoologisch muss
genannt
der nennt man lateinisch modus talent
polens das heißt es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten und eine dieser
möglichkeiten wird ausgeschlossen und
dann ist die andere übrig bleiben die
möglichkeit wahr das ist diese so habe
ich jetzt mehr formalisiertes empfiehlt
sich auch immer dann meinen
seminararbeiten dass sie versuchen die
texte auf argumente also auf prämissen
und auf konfusionen konklusion sind
diese schlüssel hin zu untersuchen und
zum schluss sehen sie vor allem anhand
von wörtern wie also folglich und daraus
folgt das machen wir jetzt mal anhand
dieses textes von david hume es sagt die
vorstellung der existenz muss entweder
aus einem besonderen eindruck stammen
damit jeder beziehung oder jedem stand
unserer vorstellung verbunden ist das
war praktisch diese sind lustig oder sie
muss mit der vorstellung der perzeption
oder des gegenstandes eines und dasselbe
sein
das ist jetzt diese dysfunktion also
entweder 1 oder 2 man kann sich
natürlich fragen gibt sich vielleicht an
der dritte option aber das scheint für
jungs sondern ausschließlich diese
option mehr alle ausschließlich eine
alternative zu sein
jetzt bestreitet jung die option 1 das
ist zwei verschiedene eindrücke gibt die
uhr mit untrennbar miteinander verbunden
gedankt werden dürfen und zwar auf
folgende weise mögen gewisse
empfindungen auch zu irgendeiner zeit
verbunden sein so finden wir doch
alsbald dass sie eine trennung zu lassen
und auch getrennt sich dem bewusstsein
darstellen können so eine vorstellung
oder empfindungen die sehr eng verbunden
ist ist zum beispiel also als
vorstellungen jetzt die vorstellung von
ursache und wirkung und die vorstellung
von kausalität wir haben es damit immer
mit einer ursache zu tun die der wirkung
vorausgeht wenn auch nur zeitlich sehr
kurz aber die immer sehr eng verbunden
sind
dennoch sagt jung dabei handelt es sich
bei kausalität nicht um eine einzelne
empfindung an einzelnen sinnes eindruck
oder vorstellen sondern genau genommen
geht es hier um 2.10 es eindrücke also
sind es ein druck auf den tennis
eindruck bisher regelmäßig folgt also
wir können das ganze immer noch weiter
analysieren also bestreitet er
und jetzt erfolgt die konklusion und das
wort so nach zeit jetzt an dass sich
hier im schlusshandel so nach kann so
gewiss jeder eindruck und jede
vorstellung deren wir uns erinnern von
uns als existieren betracht wird die
vorstellung die existenz nicht aus einen
besonderen eindruck start
anders formuliert die vorstellung der
existenz muss also genau dasselbe sein
wie die vorstellung dessen was wir uns
als existierend vergegenwärtigen als
essenz das wesen und die existenz sehen
wir hier bei david hume werden sehr
problematisch und existenz ist jetzt
nicht etwas was noch zusätzlich zu der
vorstellung seines eindruck auftritts an
der sinneseindruck selbst verbirgt wie
ich schon sagte seine existenz das ist
also ein zentraler punkt und jetzt ist
es so dass jung diese trennung von
essens- und existenz trennt die wir
mittelalter gesehen hatten
die die trennung wird kritisiert und da
ist folgendes zitat zentrales an
irgendetwas einfach denken und an etwas
als an
ein existierendes denken sind nicht zwei
verschiedene dinge
die vorstellung der existenz führt wenn
sie mit der vorstellung eines beliebigen
gegenstand das verbunden ist nichts zu
ihr hin zu was immer wir vorstellen
stellen wir als existieren vor
ja dieser gegenstand dieser beliebigen
gegenstand denen könnte man jetzt als
essenz fassen
und sobald wir überhaupt einen
gegenstand vorstellen sagt er stellen
wir in uns als existieren vor
wir können uns also nichts vorstellen
was nicht als vorgestelltes existieren
würde insofern wie etwas vorstellen hat
es schon eine gewisse existenz und hier
wird jetzt der begriff des gegenstandes
sehr wichtig auf den nämlich alexius
meinung auf dem wir jetzt in der sitzung
danach noch genauer eingehen werden
näher eingeht spricht dann von einer
gegenstands lehre also von der
wissenschaft die sich mit dem gegenstand
als solch also mit vorstellungs objekten
oder mitgefühls objekten befasst das
weiß schon voraus auf diese debatte bei
meinungen
dann haben wir noch ganz kurz diesen
denke hier angesprochen nämlich jemanden
erkannte auch hier will ich jetzt nicht
allzuweit vorgreifen ich will nur noch
dieses zitat von ihm noch einmal in
erinnerung rufen das bezieht sich jetzt
auf das verhältnis von essenz und
existenz er sagt wenn ich das prädikat
in einem identischen urteile als
identisches urteil ist analytisches
urteil aufheben und behaltet das objekt
so entspringt ein widerspruch und daher
sage ich jedes kommt diesem
notwendigerweise zu
das wäre praktisch auch in essential
ersatz nach leibnitz hebe ich aber das
objekt zustand also zusammen mit dem
prädikate auf so entspringt kein
widerspruch denn es ist nichts mehr
welche widersprochen werden könnte ein
dreieck also triangel setzen und doch
die drei winkel derselben aufheben ist
widersprechen aber den triangel samt
seien drei winkel aufheben ist kein
widerspruch
gerade eben so ist es mit dem begriff
eines absolut notwendigen
die wand also erkannt untersucht das
verhältnis von essens- und existenz mit
blick auf ein absolut notwendiges wesen
also mit blick auf den begriff gottes
und seine theorie kritisiert diesen
ontologischen gottesbeweis der von
verschiedenen denkt an die mittelalter
wie zum beispiel anselm von canterbury
geäußert wurde
und der besagt im begriff gottes also in
seiner essenz liegt schon seine existenz
also indem wir gott als sein seinem
wesen nachfassen denken müssen wir
sogleich von seiner existenz ausgehen
weil wenn gott im sinne der mächtigkeit
seiner begriffsdefinition nicht
existieren würde dann wäre er nicht
allmächtig
aber wir haben ja gerade zugestanden
dass gott allmächtig und jedenfalls im
weitesten sinne der möglichkeiten
real ist und daraus müsste dann nach
dieser mittelalterlichen theorie auch
seine existenz voll und das bestreitet
eben kommt jetzt mit diesem beispiel
ich habe jetzt hier nochmal den
veranschaulichung dieses argument
gemacht also wir haben jetzt mit dem
identischen satz oder nach leibnitz an
essential ersatz manchmal auch
analytischer satz genannt nehme mal das
subjekt junggesellen also die frage wer
da war es in der in der syntax und das
prädikat sind unverheiratet
wenn wir jetzt sagen junggesellen sind
unverheiratet oder dreiecke haben drei
winkel deswegen dasselbe dann haben wir
sie mit einem essential mit einem
notwendigen satz zu tun der ist
notwendigerweise war weil dieses
prädikat hier in diesem fall
unverheiratet sein im subjekt
junggeselle analytisch enthalten ist ein
anderes beispiel wir haben wieder das
subjekt junggesellen prädikat sind nicht
unfallraten dass wir also wenn wir
dieses prädikat aufheben wie kann
spricht aufheben bedeutet wie reagieren
dass wir setzen einfach diese negation
zeichen dieses logische davor wir
könnten auch sagen es ist nicht der fall
dass sie unverheiratet
und jetzt hätten wir dann den satz
junggeselle sind nicht unverheiratet
dass wir jetzt natürlich keine
identischer satz mehr sondern dass wir
ein widersprüchlicher satz der in sich
widersprüchlichen ja jetzt sagte er
folgendes wenn ihr das dasein dasselbe
dieses wesens aufheben oder dieses
subjekt zu hebt ihr das ding selbst mit
allen seinen prädikaten auf wo soll als
dann der widerspruch herkommen also wenn
wir jetzt den begriff des junggesellen
aufheben also nicht setzen nicht diese
annahme machen dass es junggesellen gibt
und dazu auch das prädikat unverheiratet
aufheben dann ergibt sich nach kant
daraus kein widerspruch der widerspruch
ergibt sich nur dann wenn wir das
subjekt setzen und dann eben diese
notwendigen eigenschaften absprechen
aber es geht letztendlich noch kann
darum ob wir überhaupt das subjekt
setzen wollen
ob wir überhaupt dazu berechtigt sind
dieses subjekt zu setzen
das ist jetzt also in kürze diese these
und ich habe noch ein zitat das sehen
sie auch noch vor ihr habt also gesehen
dass wenn ich das prädikat eines urteils
zusammen mit dem subjekte aufheben
niemals ein innerer widerspruch
entsprechen könne das prädikat mag auch
sein welches ist es wolle
nun bleibt euch keine aus noch übrig als
er muss sagen es gibt subjekte die gar
nicht aufgehoben werden können die also
bleiben müssen das würde aber ebenso
viel sagen als es gibt schlechterdings
notwendiges objekte eine voraussetzung
an deren richtigkeit ich eben bezweifelt
deren möglichkeiten mit zeigen wollten
denn ich kann mir nicht den geringsten
begriffen einem dinge machen welches
wenn es mit allen seinen prädikaten
aufgehoben würde ein widerspruch zurück
lese und ohne den widerspruch habe ich
durch lose reine begriffe a priori kein
merkmal der unmöglichkeit
also wie gesagt kann geht es darum
einmal ob wie ein subjekt setzen und ihm
dann ein prädikat bestreiten was ihm
eigentlich notwendige weise
kommen oder ob wir überhaupt das subjekt
setzen und dann etwas zucker absprechen
und das betrifft jetzt endet die frage
nach einem notwendigen wesen und hier
zeigt sich dass kann diese trennung von
essens- und existenz die im mittelalter
sehr sehr zentral war so nicht mehr
mitmachen